you guys love getting under Charles's  skin whose delight in it you love  driving what bugs in the most what bugs  Charles most one thing I know one thing  that does yeah with that we start  sometimes on the show when impromptu you  a little drumline yeah I hate y'all man  oh why is that why is that where's that  body so there you go bodies because  we're not supposed to be beatin on drunk  we're supposed to be talking about  basketball I'm making people enjoy this  yeah no really who isn't at all  there's II think it's because you have  no rhythm no we're exactly  I will admit I don't have a lot of  rhythm okay wait let me rephrase it we  don't have a lot of room don't include  me on Conan I was thinking you want to  show minute time you're not exactly the  most talented guy lyrically  [Applause]  sure sensuality right there seriously  you go I thought you hurt yourself did  hurt myself